[Music]
what i saw was something i think a lot
of
people who are conservative have seen
before which is that i was
i liked the civilization i came from
um i i loved it
i wanted it to continue um i thought it
had all sorts of wonderful nurturing
things that i wanted other people to
have access to as well
i didn't want to tear down my society i
wanted to keep it up
and that is the conservative instinct
and i realized i had it even as a lot of
my contemporaries
many of whom were from far more
privileged backgrounds than myself
thought that they should tear down their
society and
radically alter it and i just didn't
share that
that view and gradually came to the
realization that
that that yeah this was an unusual
position i held but
it was correct so it sounds like you
were acting out of instinct
yes it was instinct i mean um you you
you get it at
certain points in your life don't you
were a great influence
friend of mine the late roger scrutin
once described to me
that his realization he was a
conservative came in paris in 1968
when he saw these middle class students
throwing bricks at working class
policemen
and realized that he wanted paris
like london to continue he didn't want
to tear it down
and i had a similar perhaps less
dramatic steadier
realization of a similar instinct in my
adolescence i suppose i i did i didn't
want to destroy the society i thought
that
i thought it could be improved but it
had to continue
i didn't think that the other things on
offer were better
um i didn't think the dreams of the
radical left
sounded good to me i didn't like very
very basic i mean these are these are
instinct things as you know but
i didn't like the idea of everyone being
the same
i just thought it was a boring view of
society
i didn't want us all to live in the same
houses or have the same gardens or
you were for diversity before being for
diversity yes before i knew it
uh and i i didn't want everyone to have
the same views and to have to read the
same books and to
like the same things i thought that
difference
was a wonderful thing and that didn't
mean that unfairness wouldn't exist or
should be celebrated but
but yes i i didn't like the offer that i
always saw the left as holding out to me
um at a very instinctive level so
um i i accidentally became a
conservative i think you have unusual
clarity
you can see things very clearly as they
happen
and i that's obviously the first step to
improving things and to
and you also seem to have a balanced
life in the middle of this maelstrom
well we have to balance our lives don't
we i mean um we all know people who've
gone mad
in recent years um some of us people
quite close to us and mainly it's
because we've lost perspective
we've lost perspective on what matters
we've lost perspective on how to view
things the correct the correct
perspective to
to look at life um we've lost a lot
and we have to regain it i don't think
the things once lost the impossible to
regain
um i mean you know we live in this era
where
we imagine that we can know anything
because we can google it
but we've lost wisdom we've lost
knowledge we've lost experience we've
lost perspective
and we have to find a way to get back to
that i think one way back to it is to
admire it
and to seek to get it back
uh to admire people who know things we
don't know
i mean that's that's one of the things
we've completely lost
isn't it in our era everybody thinks
they know everything
um and can lecture everyone else
because of that are you surprised by the
ignorance on display oh i mean american
ignorance is just
heroic it's it's her
american ignorance is heroic i mean i
mean you know i've spent all my life as
an admirer of
america great friendship from the moment
i first came to this country my teenage
years i just
loved and admired it yes but my god it's
gone wrong
i mean we're now at this stage where
countries like
my own country of birth great britain
are actually having to try to cut
ourselves off from american influence
you know that's how bad american
influence has become
the french as you know the french are
trying to cut themselves off from it
the president of france had to recently
say we
can't have these american imports of the
ideas the america the french academy
french french
academics are saying we can't
allow this american import in what is
the import it's stupidity
it's it's it's evangelical stupidity
of i don't know why i'm laughing it's so
awful terrible but it's true
it's terrible and i mean i i hope i you
know your
viewers understand i'm saying this as a
friend an admirer
and i don't say it because i hate
america i say it because i love america
and i wish it could do better
i just i just fear this this
this this ignorance and this
this lack of desire to get perspective
on things and to have humility
intellectual humility all i hear is
these awful products of the american
academy
berating everyone else about things and
knowing so little and
it's it's it's it's worrying american
culture is currently ripping through the
rest of the world
and i don't think it works in america
and it certainly doesn't work elsewhere
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else